foreign
[Music]
I put on this big ass backpack this
morning
and I hiked
because I'm like I'm hiking next week
you know all right right
and the Packers are gonna have all my
[__] for five days what are you gonna be
safe yeah yeah there's no no Grizzlies I
found out which is kind of sick all
right like the guy like the guy like
that has done this before and it's like
kind of like leading our crew or
whatever he told us to get bear bins
which are these massive [__] jugs
that you put all your food in then you
you like secure them and you like hang
them up got it so I was like freaking
out that
I was like [__] there's gonna be tons of
bears like enough where you need this
where they're probably gonna approach
the campsite but right I found out
there's no Grizzlies out there it's just
black bears like thank God now I can
just carry this raw meat in my hands
yeah exactly yeah this Ross this raw
salmon that's why I was worried is that
I couldn't bring my raw salmon yeah some
of you your mom should be worried about
doing this hike
oh
because of their because they're hot
okay yeah
the Bears are going to come out from
behind the trees and be like [__] hey
yeah exactly it's not that they're going
to get attacked you're going to wake up
and your your mom is going to be flirted
with by a bear yeah he's just gonna be
arm up on the tree
they're brown bears though yeah not that
that's a that's not a no so they're
nothing but the color I'm saying so
they're Greek brown bears like they're
like just gentler they're like betas
okay I wouldn't say that they kind of
are brown Grizzlies are the ones that
like attack and now I'm gonna get
[__] attacked by a brown bear so
knock on wood but the brown bears like
eat berries and like they're like oh
they're just like oh
you know you're gonna be thinking about
this when you're walking up the trail
next week and you're like he's just in
front of you like oh so I'm a [__]
right what'd you say yeah yeah yeah oh
song like berries right
I think that's what you were saying
right like I only like berries
that's what you said
no first no you're sure boys yo yo oh
it's the dude oh it's the dude oh yo oh
you're the one that said we only like
berries right and then one of their boys
do you have any berries for us because
we're all pretty hungry we love some
berries if you had some and then one
other boys walks out behind you with a
with a Paw full of berries and he mushes
it on your forehead yeah yeah and he
starts rubbing it all over your head and
he's like yo boys I think we found a big
blueberry right here
and they're like yo
thank God
no we don't we don't eat humans at all
but blueberries we definitely do eat
those thank God what we're seeing right
now is a big old blueberry oh
right what are you you're not a human
right no I'm a I'm a blueberry yeah you
are a little blueberry yeah yeah see
like if you came across this you'd be
like
okay okay I think that's what it swipes
you
like look at that that's a black bear
just cool you know what I mean you'd
kick it
you gotta assert like dominance then you
would kick that
that dude just passed her out and just
like if I forgot the rules you know I'd
try to do the rhyme in my head
Brown laid down black fight back kick in
the nuts kicking the nuts yeah and then
oh
[Laughter]
oh no
oh no yo you guys
come on
it's a Baron's Trail
I got it they're like
[Laughter]
you peel them off the tree he doesn't
even try to find out oh no dude that's
so [__]
pumpkin
I'm getting rid of your violent
your violent ass yeah before you kill me
my family I'm getting rid of you you
broke your piece of [__] I'm new I knew
you were thinking about it damn damn
it looks stupid as [__]
good he's got that little kid in trouble
face
oh [__] man oh their eyes are so small
what the hell
man I really hope I don't get attacked
by a bear next week because this whole
segment is just gonna be do you think no
go back go back to that go back to that
big boy you think he's attacking you he
just wants some macaroni yeah yeah sure
you're like thinking he's gonna like ah
you're like oh [__] he's like oh well
yeah
you got any crackers do you have any
snacks for me
what'd you do with my kid what'd you do
with my kid what did you do with my kid
oh [__]
have you seen my son
I'll get rid of you
that's a good voice
[Laughter]
bloodthirsty little [__]
absolute Bloodhound violent little
[__] aren't you yeah I know he's I
know you smell death
oh [__]
you're gonna kill me and my whole family
weren't you yeah you were thinking about
it not before I do something about it
damn they all look so dumb Dan that
thing is a unit the the main one that
big [__] that is a union that boy just
wants to eat oh
no dude imagine like you just see this
like in real time
and then like
just over it just like a like a 4X scope
oh no
stand back oh dude
I see something just a dumbass dad with
a revolver yeah yeah [__] Forex scope
and he's six feet away from it oh
yeah I'm about to get rid of this little
[__]
[Laughter]
yeah look at this piece of [__]
yeah you know we call these yeah
Straight From Hell
yeah
yeah this is what they're talking about
in the Bible
they're [__] demons diesel [__]
they'll tear your [__] throat out
little banshees man I got the spirit of
all kinds of evil in them
you know what are you gonna do with them
we're gonna burn it ah Chuck them off
this clip I think
that usually does it burn it up ah we're
gonna we got a big old pile back at the
uh back at the State Park uh a facility
we got a pile open we're gonna burn them
oh
oh sorry too much I took it there sorry
honey
I see a bear
[Laughter]
little Teddy Graham
stand back I'll take care of it stupid
ass like [__] uh Chevy Chase ass dad
with a revolver hold on kids
I got him
what do you mean don't you dare come
near I'm near my family oh [__]
see look at him they're really cute
now now you might look at this and think
oh man what a cute little he just got
done eating someone's baby yeah